even though it still looks seaworthy
this 30 year old polish freighter is
being retired it is being dismantled in
northeastern Denmark two-thirds of it is
steel which will be melted down and
recycled on a neighboring fishing
trawler ship recycler killed [ __ ] hole
makes a few valuable finds this fairly
new cable winch is worth around seventy
thousand euros the value we're on the
bridge and this ship would be there soon
assets tucsonaz one you one here and one
on the back but much of the boat cannot
be recycled such as the cabin and the
wall sheathing
the individual materials have to be
sorted by hand and disposed of by
experts this is much more expensive in
Europe than in india or bangladesh where
most ships are now scrapped it has
changed a lot and 10 years ago a company
like like us could put recycler vessel
settle the metal and that was okay
business today there is a lot of
competition and today to survive in
recycling you'll have to sell a lot of
spare parts not just this deal the
individual components are stored here at
the wrecking yard a little bit of rust
isn't a problem and boat owners can drop
by and turn up a few treasures shipping
company owner Michelle jewels guard is a
repeat customer there's plenty good
ships coming here and
because of the market in the shipping so
so sorry okay yeah you can you can find
some compute things this Danish ship
recycler has customers from all over
many people who bring their boats to be
scrapped do it because they want to make
sure that their boats are scrapped in an
environmentally friendly way it is
getting more and more important for
everybody I guess everybody is looking
on the environment and looking on the
yeah the environmental issues so for
bigger shipping companies or offshore
companies it's very important to have a
green profile in the end it looks like a
pile of junk but just a few days ago
this heap of Steel was still a ship